with the Stargate franchise is it
definite they were going to be getting a
movie first or are other options
possible
TV series
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so recently Nepal I asked you guys what
do you actually want from the new
Stargate franchise do you want a movie
with returning actors from the original
franchises do you want a returning movie
with new actors do you want a TV series
with returning actors from the sg1 it's
the USDA or do you want a new TV series
with completely new actors nearly 70
percent of you said you want a TV series
with at least some returning actors from
sg1 SG USGA
70 percent
but Amazon are seemingly going with the
movie plan
but is that the only plan in action
right now or is a TV series first still
possible well I've been talking to one
on my sources recently somebody I've
spoken to for a little while and they've
been telling me about this Hackman group
that I spoke about in the last video and
how actually Amazon might have a much
bigger plan than we realized that even
though they were looking at working with
something like Warner bro this and look
to be honest there's still loads of
projects with Warner Brothers at Amazon
are planning
um but they were looking at working with
somebody like Amazon to get a lot of
these projects with MGM up and running
much quicker than they could if they
were going to do them on their own but
actually they're moving away from that
and they are actually going to be
accelerating their plans to get Studio
space with the Hackman group and that
they're going to be going alone with a
lot of these MGM projects like Stargate
and RoboCop while I was chatting to him
he was telling me that there does seem
to be a general plan within Amazon for
the Stargate franchise and that will be
to get two or three sound stages
possibly in Vancouver Stargate could go
home and actually they would be running
Stargate projects out of there pretty
much constantly so that they would be
doing TV series movies and potentially
other projects maybe miniseries and
things like that out of those two or
three sound stages that they would be
solely for Stargate now they're a very
good financial reasons why Amazon want
to do this something like the Stargate
franchise is going to be expensive but
there are lots of ways they can save a
little bit of money now one of the ways
they can do that is by being efficient
and actually sharing props now if you
think about it that's a really good idea
nowadays TV series particularly on
streaming services are expected to look
like mini movies they're expected to
have almost cinematic quality
and that really has become an
expectation that when they fall short
rings of power hmm
people actually really complain about it
so one way that you could get cinematic
quality in a TV series is by sharing the
sound stages the props
etc etc the cameras
from The Cinematic movie so you film a
cinematic movie and you film the TV
shows at the same time you run them side
by side you have actors jumping between
the two again adding to the efficiency
of the project and efficiency means
money saved so Amazon quite like this
idea
my source was also saying though that
the thing is with that a TV series if it
was going to be running alongside a
movie like that could be produced much
quicker we could get that on the
streaming service within say nine months
whereas the movie will probably take
about 18 months so
the possibility of getting a TV series
first is still very real and that is at
the end of the day what we want it also
makes sense from a practical point of
view because we've had nearly 15 years
since SGU A lot's going to have changed
in the Stargate Universe a TV series
will allow us to fill many of those
blanks and then set up the movie could
imagine this we get a TV series again it
explains why now maybe the Stargate
program is you know revealed to the
public the state of planet Earth now the
state of the universe our relationship
with the Jaffa and so on and so on it
gives us a really exciting story but at
the end of that 10 episodes a
cliffhanger
Cliffhanger that sets up the movie now
for me that solves a lot of problems
like I say we fill in all the gaps we
build that little bit of History we
build a foundation that the movie can
then jump off and we lower the risk that
the movie would fail you have a TV
series that would almost act like a
massive advert for that cinematic movie
and we are seeing at the moment that a
lot of movies being released at the
cinema are not doing very well Indiana
Jones should have been a slam dunk but
it kind of flopped The Flash flopped
massively it wasn't very good though
Indiana Jones is actually okay so a
cinematic release is a huge risk why not
have at least a mini series even you
know three or four episodes something to
give the movie a little bit more of a
Kickstart and a little bit more chance
of success
How likely is all of this well the
source is actually saying that he
doesn't believe an actual final decision
has been made now why has a decision
been made on the movie Why has Jennifer
salkey actually instructed Courtney
Valentini the new head of film at MGM
and Prime to begin development work on
the film before maybe making the
decision on the TV series Etc well my
guy is saying basically that setting up
a movie
takes ages and the development work
needs to start now if it's going to
happen in the next three years
so getting permission for the movie to
start
is kind of a no-brainer but the guys
also said to me actually the permission
for the TV series happened ages ago
development work for the TV series and
The Wider project of Stargate happened
ages ago Joseph malozi was talking about
this six months ago other people were
talking about it I've been talking about
it for 18 months I've told you that MGM
genuinely believe they're going to be
allowed to push forward with Brad
Wright's project just over a year ago
and that as soon as Amazon took over MGM
they began talking about Stargate with
the idea of it being a tent pole project
for them I.E a big project for them so
when I asked this to the source I went
out so when I asked the source why are
we looking at a movie
he's actually said look at what deadline
wrote and that's important because the
deadline story that we're talking about
about Stargate said probably a movie
first and he said look the word probably
is important because that will have come
directly from Amazon that is Amazon
talking to deadline that is them saying
there is a movie coming
but it might not be first
and that is exactly what the source has
been telling me actually for quite some
time that we're going to be getting this
development work and this project of a
series and a movie hand in hand and that
how they then decide to deliver that has
not quite been finalized
because it's going to depend on
directors showrunners
etc etc these people are not actually in
place yet and no final decision will be
made until they are in place even though
a lot of the development work is being
done
so we could still get a series first
people we could actually get the Marvel
style franchise that I was talking about
a year ago that movies and TV series
that actually influence each other that
actually go hand in hand with each other
and that I think is really really
exciting I honestly believe we could be
getting straight to streaming movies
straight to cinema movies miniseries
longer series I actually think we could
be getting some animation as well
because Amazon really do seem to be
trying to put their full weight behind
Stargate they genuinely do believe this
is a franchise that can challenge Star
Trek Star Wars even and the only way
they're going to do that is by throwing
everything at it
it looks like that's what they're doing
but guys I want to know what you think
is a TV series first really really
important and if you think it is why
I've told you why I think it is but I
want to know what you think
if you are new to the channel don't
forget to like subscribe and hit that
Bell notification so you never miss any
of our new videos and really do go and
have a look at patreon it really
supports the channel and you get a free
gift you can see the address at the
bottom here as always guys please stay
safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]